a Donald Trump appears totally off the
rails in a recent series of tweets about
the Moon and Mars the tweets are as
bonkers as they are hypocritical neither
of which is a shock from the current
president now I've been talking about
space exploration and NASA funding
forever on this program and sadly
there's a big part of the country that
just doesn't see the importance of space
exploration and there's another part of
the country that likes space exploration
but only as a military industrial
complex sort of testing ground for new
weapons and military tacker as part of
expanding American Empire and
colonialism to space but in reality
exploring space is a really important
thing for humans an important endeavor
for humans to undertake the ambition and
curiosity element are part of it but
that's kind of a more general thing
there's a life-saving component right
having the ability to save huge numbers
of people from asteroids and comets but
by being able to deflect them could be a
really big thing for Humanity in the
future depending on how long we think
humans can stay on planet earth at a
certain point we're going to need some
other place to go if homo sapiens is
going to continue existing earth is not
going to be home to humans forever it'll
probably still be home for a long time
but if we want a place to eventually go
we need to be exploring space space
exploration could lead to huge
developments in mitigating climate
change we don't know what's out there
and what we might find and what
developments might stem from there so
anyway Republicans sometimes want to
explore space sometimes they don't
sometimes they want to do it but only
with private industry instead of NASA
sometimes NASA is ok and Donald Trump
tweeted over the weekend that we
shouldn't go to the moon and that the
moon is part of Mars
I guess he means like in a more general
sense of space exploration Donald Trump
tweeting very strangely quote for all of
the money we are spending NASA should
not be talking about going to the moon
we did that 50 years ago they should be
focused on the much bigger things we are
doing including Mars
of which the moon is a part defense and
science a Trump later tweeting also that
moon pie is not really made of moon
rocks right in the in the under the
category of what is extraordinarily
obvious so the immediate reaction was is
Trump saying that the moon is part of
Mars what is wrong with this guy what
the hell is going on he's weaponized
ignorance now all of those reactions are
true and accurate but I don't think
Trump thinks the moon is part of Mars
I believe what Donald Trump is trying to
say here is something like the moon is
part of the eventual Martian project
going to the moon in and of itself is a
means and not an end or something like
that I mean I don't exactly know what he
was trying to say but the most important
thing is that this is the opposite of
what Donald Trump said three weeks ago
three weeks ago Donald Trump tweeted on
May 13th under my administration we are
restoring NASA to greatness and we are
going back to the moon then Mars
I am updating my budget to include an
additional 1.6 billion dollars so that
we can return to space in a big way but
then over the weekend he says NASA
should not be talking about going to the
moon we did that 50 years ago we should
be exploring space no matter what Donald
Trump says we should be funding it so
much technology has come as a derivative
from space exploration and as far as
Donald Trump Trump Trump's tweets here I
don't think he literally believes the
moon is part of Mars I think that we
should stop trying to read so much into
his tweets these are the rantings of an
ignorant and unstable person period if
you imagine you know being on the Boston
or New York subway for example which
I've had the privilege of doing hundreds
of times you don't necessarily try to
read into the specifics of what the guy
urinating in the back of the subway car
is saying about Jesus is coming right
you don't you recognize it for what it
is you understand the context and you
say it's not really worth trying to read
into so specifically I think we
increasingly need to see Donald Trump's
tweets in sort of the same way these are
the erratic on
things that occur to Donald Trump and
that he tweets before anybody can
actually talk sense into him I don't
know exactly what he meant by the moon
as part of Mars what I do know is that
in just three and a half weeks Donald
Trump appears to have completely done a
180 on whether we should be doing this
space exploration and whether we should
be going to the moon and that's the real
concern and that's the concern
geopolitically when Donald Trump swims
change and it makes it so that other
countries can't see the United States as
a reliable negotiating partner as a
reliable partner in all sorts of
different ways which they rightly can't
under Donald Trump because as we've seen
with the Iran deal he will on a whim say
even though Iran hasn't violated it I'm
just going to bail out that's the real
danger here does Trump think the moon is
a piece of Mars I don't think so
but who knows what Trump really actually
thinks I'm curious what you think Trump
meant by this tweet